c'est l'une des régions les plus
bombardés de l'ukraine la région de
karkhiv sa capitale du même nom n'est
jamais passé sous contrôle russe
contrairement à d'autres villages de la
zone ce mercredi soir le président
volodymyr et nice qui a annoncé la
reprise de plusieurs d'entre eux
cette semaine nous avons de bonnes
nouvelles de la région de karkhiv
vous avez probablement déjà vu des
rapports sur l'activité des défenseurs
de l'ukraine mais ce n'est pas encore le
moment de nommer ces localités où le
drapeau ukrainien est revenue
ces derniers jours des observateurs
faisaient état d'une percée des forces
chrétiennes dans la région des
informations qui n'ont pas été vérifiées
de manière indépendante
au sud la contre-offensive ukrainienne
se poursuit toujours du côté de
personnes occupées par les russes la
ville peuplée de 280 mille habitants
avant la guerre est l'objectif numéro un
du gouvernement et craignent un peu
d'informations filtrent sur cette
offensive mais le président ukrainien a
revendiqué des avancées et la reprise de
plusieurs localités dans l'ouest de la
région